[Music]
okay members uh apologies for absence
have been received from councelor Daniel
belon councelor Andrew cross and
councelor James Gooding are there any
other
apologies substitute members councelor
Richard Lindon substituting for
councelor Andrew cross and counselor Ian
Foster substituting for counselor Mrs
Danielle Belton thank you non members
attending uh councelor Mrs Julie Gooding
councelor Michael Hoy uh councelor James
newo and councelor Jim
Crips members M minutes of the meeting
held on the 5th of December can I ask
are these noted and agreed members up uh
councilor won thank you madam chair um
if I take you to page four and page five
in respect of the key DEC decisions
document and the work plan firstly on
the key decisions document uh I think it
says there uh reference to the fact that
in the next iteration of this document
that we reference to the Clement Hall
location I might have missed it but uh I
couldn't see it off hand if anyone is
able to point it to me on the uh on the
key decisions document I presume that's
the one at the back of tonight's agenda
uh and also on the work plan uh the
um meeting in the work plan that we
considered our meeting on the 5th of
December uh it quite clearly shows the
agenda for the 9th of January and if by
magic all those items uh from a council
meeting on the nth of agenda appear on a
very Hefty document tonight um and it's
a bit of disappointment to see meetings
cancelled and then a very Hefty agenda
and I'm sure you agree with me Madam
chair but uh that's an observation but I
would be interested on the Clement's
call reference thank you thank you um I
I do concur with you councelor won and I
apologize that meeting was cancelled um
unfortunately officers advised and we
couldn't do anything um else would you
like to um comment somebody on
[Music]
CL any officers
no
thank you chair good evening members um
in the absence of um any other um hands
up to respond um I'll just say that I'll
take that away to the executive um
because of course the executive is the
body that determines the key decisions
document Council won well my question
was Madam chair have I missed it because
I might have missed it but is it there
can anyone else see it on the current
iteration of the key decision
document
chair if I may I can confirm it's not on
the published
version Council Orton that will be taken
back to the executive say it's missing
thank you did I see another hand raised
sorry members um back to the agenda um
item number five to receive Declarations
of interest uh counselor Mrs
Mason uh thank you madam chairman I've
received advice that I should absence
myself from item six and seven because
as I was part of the process that you're
examining I would obviously be
predetermined so I will leave the hall
then thank you actually I might as well
leave
now thank you Mrs N um uh councelor Mrs
N um where will you be because then we
can send an officers to find
you
okay correct thank
[Music]
you
agenda item six is our
20242 budget and 2024 to 29 medium-term
Financial strategy um titim Willis our
officer will introduce this report
Council Hoy is also in attendance and
may assist with any other the questions
thank
you thank you chair um good evening
members um this sets out the budget for
next year 2425 and the medium-term
financial strategy which has been
extended to five years up 28
29 the headlines are uh proposed council
tax increase of
2.99% um no borrowing over the
medium-term financial strategy fees and
charges for next year generally Rising
with
inflation um a balanced budget for next
year as well as a balanced budget for
the year after and the year after that
with no use of reserves to support those
budgets um and this demonstrates a sound
and responsible approach to managing the
council's finances despite severe
pressure on budgets as a result of
largely as a result of
inflation there is a great deal of
uncertainty regarding the economic
backdrop and government funding for the
budget and the medium-term financial
strategy we can maintain our minimum
level of working balances of 10% of net
revenue expenditure as per Council
policy and acceptable to me as the
section1 officer when writing the
Assurance statement for Council and over
the medium term the table on page 6.9
summarizes the budgets for the five
years there are projected shortfalls in
years four and five whilst these
shortfalls are of some concern they are
only predictions in the context of
substantial
uncertainty despite this uncertainty we
nonetheless wish to highlight some of
the actions planned over the medium term
which are designed to generate income
and reduce costs which are set out on
pages 6.7 and
6.8 on the capital program there is a
5year capital program presented um and
to avoid borrowing we are using receipts
from asset Sals and earmarked reserves
the ear marked reserves that are to be
used to fund the capital program come
from the revenue budget sometimes
building them up when we can then to
spend on
investment the amount of reserves
available to fund the capital program
will become exhausted over the
medium-term financial strategy period
this has been recognized by limiting the
program over the five years whilst we've
identified some specific schemes a
number of others will be subject to a
value for money assessment starting next
financial year in 2425 to decide which
should be prioritized this is explained
and Quantified on page
6.14 so there's very little room for
maneuver um we K continue to strive for
efficiencies but there are ongoing cost
increases and pressures on the income
any spare funding is being used to
support investment in assets and
services but the overall position is
delicate so any significant unfunded
cost could prompt the need to reduce
services or to
borrow if the C tax increase was reduced
by 1% it would cost the council £450,000
over the MTF period um mtfs period and
990,000 a year every year
thereafter uh our earmarked reserves are
set out on page
6.17 and they demonstrate how reserves
are used to fund the capital program at
the start of this year they they stood
at about 13.3 million but they are
projected to be just below 5 million at
the end of next year the use of these
reserves is planned and they're not
being used to fund ongoing expenditure
only oneoff costs but their projected
reduction does highlight how this
Council along with most other councils
across the country is having to utilize
reserves to sustain services and
investment
therein the process from this point is
for this scrutiny committee to
scrutinize the proposals make any
recommendations to the executive and the
executive will meet on the 8th of
February to consider these
recommendations and then finalize its
proposed budget and mtfs to the council
which will meet on the 20th of February
with those budget
proposals one further point I'd make um
chair is the Secretary of State um wrote
to councils on the 24th of January in
relation to the provisional settlement
which was announced on the 18th of
December um so in advance of the final
settlement which is dueing February I
was told today the 6th of February um
but what he said was that there'll be
600 million P more available to local
government as compared to the
provisional settlement of which 500
million so from the 600 500 million is
for social care so not available to
districts like ours um but there is some
extra funding available to districts is
the promise we don't know how much that
will be at this stage because we haven't
got to the final settlement which we
should have um sometime next week I'm
happy to answer any questions thank you
chair thank you Tim um members before we
start as Council Orton put uh pointed
out we've got a full agenda so I would
ask everybody to keep the
questions succinct and to the
paper thank you uh councelor Foster
thank you chairman um on page
6.1 I received the report for tonight's
meeting on the 24th of
January um the report summary says this
report was presented to the executive on
the 5th of January which was after this
report came out um my question is was
there anything in the executive meeting
that happened after this report was
issued that we should be reported upon
as an addendum or any further
information thank you Tim um thank you
chair um the the future reference date
was because I thought we'd be reading it
tonight which was after the 20 after the
25th of of January um from my memory and
I'm sure um Emily or or Council ho can
correct me there weren't any additional
recommendations arising or anything of
notes arising from the executive meeting
on the 25th compared to what's in front
of you
tonight thank
you councelor Mrs gson
um on page 6.5 I assume this is to Tim
or Michael I'm not sure who wants to
answer this but um on page 6.5 um
1.7 um the fourth paragraph along says
funding guaranteed of 580,000
um and then in the next in bracket says
zero in 23 24 is this the new Grant
we're receiving because all the other in
the rest of the table it shows them
going up or down but that particular one
it just says zero in
2324 so is this a new
Grant or guaranteed funding thank
you thank you chair um it's not new um
it was new for 23
24 and it continued in 24 25 for next
year um it's just that it was Zero for
rodford in 23 24 the nature of the
funding guarantee although it wasn't
apparent when it was introduced a year
ago uh increasingly looks like a
balancing figure of government funding
um so because for 2324 Rochford had a
large new homes bonus that would have
influenced the amount of funding
guarantee it received um and so it had
none whereas new hes bonus is lower for
2425 so there is a funding guarantee and
it acts as the balancing figure when the
government work out how much additions
they want to increase core spending
Power by for local government which is
why for example this extra money that
the secretary of state has announced if
we are going to receive any of that
money it will come in the form of
additional funding guarantee it does
slightly contradict the the government's
policy of arguing that new homes bonus
is is there to incentivize new homes
building if you increase your new homes
bonus but then you lose funding
guarantee and vice versa but that
appears to be what it's for but that's
why it was Zero for
2324 Council Caron you did you want to
come back on that
I've got second part to my question the
following paragraph says that the
district receive a homeless prevention
Grant um which we awaiting
confirmation then um on page
6.13 it says there's a gron of
287,000 is that the same gr is it just
appear in the different column and not
there you know was it a waiting on that
page but not no that is our best
estimate of what it's going to be which
was based on a figure for next year
based on this year um but we have yet to
be formally notified as to what that
figure is for next year right thanks Tim
so that's just an estimate in that
column
okay thank you uh councilor
Ward thank you very much chairman uh
basically it's just coming back uh to
the item just previously mentioned uh
item 1.7 on
6.5 um I do notice that in fact um the
council have done a lot better this year
in the amount that we're receiving which
is uh 1.1 million as opposed to
990,000 from last year so that's that's
very good to say that uh the national
government is actually providing
councils a little bit more but there was
something I just like to clarify um
where you were mentioning about the use
of earmarked
reserves uh to assist in the balance of
this budget um will you be looking to
reinstate those earmarked Reserves at
any time and what are the plans for
actually reinstating those ear Mar
reserves thank you chair
um at this stage over the five
there aren't plans to reinstate reserves
that used there are plans to try and
mitigate against using all those
reserves up over the fiveyear period um
I would suggest that we're going through
a period um of such uncertainty and such
pressure brought about not because
overall Government funding as we Define
it is going down because it hasn't gone
down it's gone up a little bit compared
to 23 24 but because of all the cost
pressures and expectations of local
government which have had added
substantially to to the the typical
budget gaps that are opening each year
um which I think I've described when
I've done briefings including to to your
group um so there aren't plans in the
mtfs to to reinstate or to replenish or
to increase reserves um merely to try
and find ways to avoid using them all
up would you like to come back Council
Ward yes thank thank you very much
chairman um yeah just I just want a bit
more clarity on the AAR reserves um are
there some of reserves that are less
important than others on and some which
are not necessary at
all um thank you chair there are
different types of reserves um and it's
difficult to compare one against the
other and say prioritize them in order
of importance um for example we we have
um yesterday just been finalizing our
estimates of business rates for next
year it's necessarily really late um in
fact brentwoods was finished a day late
today and Carrie Cox from rsford went
over and helped Bentwood complete theirs
today um so there are um very last
minute things that are happening and
because especially on business rates it
fluctuates because of things like um not
so much reliefs but because we get Grant
on those but appeals that can have a big
impact on our level of business rates
income we have no control over that and
so for something like that we have an
equalization Reserve we call it which is
there to try and smooth out these ups
and downs that we might have now I would
consider that to be really important
from my financial point of view um but
then there are other reserves that are
there that earmarked for investment in
the district um specifically the
investment Reserve and what was the hard
soft infrastructure Reserve which it
could be argued are really vital to
funding the capital program and
investment in in assets of the council
going forward so trying to prioritize is
not something I'd want to to try and do
I'd argue if anyone were to prioritize
them it would be members on the advice
of
offices sounds your question councelor
Ward thank you councelor won next thank
you thank you madam chair and I've got a
number of questions and um I don't know
quite whether you'd like me to say Page
by Page there's not that many but um if
I do page 6.7 first
yeah and first of all if I go to the
second bullet uh third bullet point
under
1.12 um there is an ongoing Revenue
contribution to Capital of £255,000
and presumably that is topping up
reserves in some way but uh that's one
question um if I go through um if there
could be some explanation of the use of
the newly established budget
Equalization Reserve because that would
help understanding that's the last
bullet point under
1.12 um under
6.3 uh the final bullet point there to
deliver the objectives of the council's
asset strategy um now I'm not clear
bearing in mind this is a budget paper
as to what the current objectives of the
council's asset Strate
is um and finally on that page
6.5 um it talks about aim to increase
fees and charges in general by at least
inflation prevalent at the time the
charges are set but later in the report
on page
6.13 uh
2.4 um it refers to the fact
that there is a separate report on this
agenda this agenda that sets out the
proposed fees and charges for
20242 uh these are assumed to have been
agreed for the purposes of this report
so that's the loss on you'll be pleased
to know Madam chair um that's the most
extensive of the pages in in the
questions
but thank you councilor Orton um Tim
would you like to take those or go
through those thank you thank you chair
um I will but I'll need to stop and ask
the third question because I didn't
quite pick that one up um the the first
question about the 255,000 revenue
contribution to Capital um that is used
within the capital program each year um
it's always been there it's been there
for years it's been 255,000 for many
years so effectively there's a revenue
budget we assume we spend it all because
we just put it all into fund the capital
program or contribute towards funding
the capital program and we are using all
of that completely over the five years
of the mtfs
um the equalization the budget
Equalization Reserve um what we've um
done with that is we've established it
this year we're establishing it this
year as a reserve um there is some
underspend in this year which we're
using to contribute towards the this
Reserve um and then we we start drawing
upon it in future years so the idea is
to smooth out any fluctu ations in
budget gaps over the 245 256
267 um if we if we hadn't done that I
think it's page
6.9 the um the the five-year summary you
can see budget Equalization Reserve in
there um and we've there's
193,000
um contribution to the budget
Equalization reserve and then use of in
future years beyond that so so um it's
it's an attempt to show the headline of
balanc budget
000000 no uh no budget Gap um within the
existing resources of the mtfs period I
didn't catch your third question
sorry third question was under 6.3 the
last bullet point bearing in mind this
is a budget so objective facts um to
deliver the objectives of the council's
asset strategy
um so we're talking about a budget here
thank you chair um the the budget is a
financial plan at a moment in time it's
not dealing in fax um final accounts
deal with fax not the budget it's
projections in five years time you'd
have to have a crystal ball to know what
local government Finance is going to
look like so I wouldn't ever contend
that this is a paper full of facts um
I'd like to think there aren't any any
errors in it um and in relation to
things like references to
objectives um this is always a tricky
one to try and have balanced out when
you have a financial plan and you're
projecting forward five years you would
ideally want to look at a set of
objectives and strategies that are
non-financial to inform that financial
plan but things are never that even and
we are in a state for example as regards
the asset strategy where that's still in
development as are many other strategies
and policies that don't necessarily
coincide with the um statutorily
enforced timetable of a of a budget
process um You referred also to fees and
charges um the reference to um Elsewhere
on the agenda it this is a this is a
report to overview and scrutiny and
shouldn't have been there because that
isn't on the agenda um it will be
Elsewhere on the agenda for for Council
when the the the budget
comes um did did you also have a
question about fees and charges
themselves or was that the main point uh
well I referred to the fact that of the
attachment which clearly isn't attached
um but also in relation to fees and
charges in 7.5 page
6.9 um quite clearly it is known what
the expectation is because there's a
figure quoted there of 325
million uh that's on uh page
6.10 so presumably it's just the detail
that sits behind that
figure um thank you chair yes that's the
figure that is incorporated within the
summary figures in the table on
6 nine um the fees and charges are
Incorporated in into those numbers and
so have been anticipated for 245 they
built into that 245 budget those 245
budget
figures nearly nearly there Madam chair
um on page
6.14 um I find it quite interesting um
that there is a figure quoted there of
uh 1.4 million allocation for the rord
District Council Office relocation uh
which is to be the key thing which is
assumed to be funded from the receipts
of the sale of the existing offices um
now I appreciate there may be
competitive interest why we can't go
into too much detail there but I just as
an observation I find that an
interesting figure um so I'm not
expecting a response out of deference to
the1 officer on that um thank you also
for um referring to the table on
6.16 uh another observation I find it
absolutely amazing um that uh we are
anticipating uh using e mar reserves
these aren't ear Mar reserves to fund
Services they are earmark reserves
taking us down to a frighteningly low
level over the term uh and also the
unallocated funds whilst I agree with
the principle of 10% uh we really are
scraping the cupboard uh to uh fund our
issues now uh clearly the opportunity
comes on the 20th of February uh and uh
I'm proposing an amendment because I
don't want there to be any
misunderstanding at Council um I am
proposing an amendment um uh to add on
to the existing recommendation on page
6.1 a very fair point made in
the second bullet point of 2.2 and the
amendment is to add to that existing
recommendation mindful it is not a line
by line scrutiny of the budget contents
because I think that's a very fair point
and uh We've endeavored to not go line
by line uh tonight but uh I think that
would be an appropriate thing so there's
no misunderstanding at Council that it's
assumed that we've gone through line by
line thank you madam
chair um councelor won I'm going to ask
you to actually point out exactly when
the document and read that out again for
the officer and then I will ask if
there's a seconder thank you thank you
very much so the recommendation
currently reads overview and scrutiny
committee is requested to make comment
and consider any recommendations to the
executive in respect of the attached
report and I'm asking for the words
Mindful and then the final words in the
second bullet point of 2.2 mindful it is
not a line by line scrutiny of the
budget
contents
um Council I'm just going to ask Emily
just to help with this a little thank
you thank you chair um so the way that
the covering report is is written for
this item for the overview and scrutiny
committee is to give you the freedom as
usual to make recommendations as you f
see fit and to make observations which
are then fed back to the executive so at
this moment in time you haven't got a
proposed um and seconded recommendation
on the table to amend so I think what
you will probably get to without
predetermining your discussion is a
point where the committee moves to
recommend that the executive considers
this budget report at this point Council
won you would add your wording of
mindful that this has not been a line by
line review of the budget
as as always I think that's really
helpful advice from the monitoring
officer um and I'm very content with
that all I there's obviously a lot of
people that will be at full Council
aren't sitting around this table and I'm
just Keen that it's understood what our
role has been uh in overview and
scrutiny tonight to look at the report
and there's not when we are perhaps
looking at a few lines or ideas uh
there's not uh misunderstanding uh and
whil complimenting the monitoring
officer I would just like to come back
to the section 15 one officer and say
that I always have high admiration for
the reports that he produces uh and uh I
think this is exemplary uh and there's
certainly no errors that I could find so
uh I'm full of praise for uh a very
detailed report thank you madam thank
you councelor Buton and I'm presume
councelor W you want to second
that yeah I would like to second but I
also need to ask a further
question go
ahead
now thank you very much um I would like
to actually refer back to page
6.9 uh on the table now I know we have
got other items on the agenda that will
reflect this uh and this is strategic
planning uh the amount that has been
satisfied for that I would personally
suggest that is
poultry in regards to what is going to
be required in regards to the local plan
coming forward uh I think it's an ex we
already can see from the reports we're
going to be looking at that planning the
planning department enforcement and all
the areas have been starved of resources
for many years we have a local plan to
get out and I consider the amount that
has been set aside for strategic
planning is
insufficient thank you councilor Ward so
that's um just your your comment that
you want fedback thank you thank
you um any other members
indicating uh counselor Mrs Gadson um
per
6.8 um 6 sorry um
6.6 it talks about um delivering savings
and additional income but there's no
breakdown of what the expected savings
and you know income would be I was
wondering if you could give us a steer
on
that um that goes back to Tim and I
think that is also incomes councelor
won's
comments thank you chair um the um the
reference there is to some of the bullet
point ideas that could be pursued over
the medium term in order to address the
medium-term budget Gap um If This Were
to be an accurate prediction then it
suggesting we're going to have
expenditure exceeding income by 880,000
in 2027 28 so what this this paragraph
and the preceding one is attempting to
do is to say these are the sort of
things that the council should be
considering doing over the medium term
um not to
say the world is coming to an end we've
got to take action tomorrow and start
slashing and burning through Services
now in order to address something that
let's face it it might never happen
there might not be a budget gap of
880,000 um in
2728 um so it's deliberately words and
not numbers um because it's it would it
would be premature to start um and
perhaps even fasile to start putting
numbers picking numbers out of the air
that didn't have any justification or
business case or project plan behind
them um that happened to magically come
to say the 880,000 in
2728 um what we've done is to just to
keep to words to say these are the sort
of policies and and strategies that will
need to be adopted over the coming years
if this were to come to pass the
medium-term financial strategy
projections were to come to pass I would
also say a couple of other things while
I have the opportunity um is that having
uh a budget Gap in years four and five
of the fiveyear mtfs that's actually
very good um I had a meeting of all the
other section one51 officers around
Essex this morning every one of them has
large budget gaps appearing in years
three four five sometimes year two as
well um because there's so much
uncertainty nobody can be sure about the
predictions so that there is going to be
a tendency for gaps to appear in in
later years and the other thing I'd say
is even if this came true and the worst
happened happened we would currently
have enough reserves to cover it not
that we would want to use reserves to
cover ongoing budget gaps but we would
have enough to do so which means that
there isn't any um concerns about not
just approving a balanced budget by
Council but approving a balanced
medium-term Financial strategy too thank
you thank you Tim um I can see now
councelor um Foster and I think this
will be the the last person to see thank
you right thank you madam chair um I'm
referring to page
6.21 under the resources climate change
and economy
U heading um the budget for 20123 was
$884,000 which was an actual of 941,618
seems to be based upon increasing
operating income from 275,000 to 650,000
so perhaps wouldn't expect an answer on
that tonight when it comes to budget
discussion we need to understand how
that incomes increased from
275,000 to 650,000
thank you councelor Foster I think um
Tim or councelor who might like to pick
up on that
one thank you chairman um I'm not sure
of the figure you're talking about I
know the climate emergency committee met
last night it may be that some of those
decisions have been fed in already into
the budget um I'm happy to get back to
all members on this tomorrow if that's
possible to give those figures so you
have I know it doesn't help with you
what you recommend tonight I can get you
the information for tomorrow okay thank
you thank you um okay members um I've
just got um a couple of points here
um again um it's disappointing that we
um only had 329 responses to our budget
survey um bearing in mind we've got a
population of
87,000 um so that's something for the
executive to note and perhaps take
forward for future consultations and
surveys um
our residents um they they don't look at
percentages to be honest they look at
the bottom figure in how much is this is
going to cost them um it has there on
page 6.3 under c um an amount of
755 some people may seem small to others
when it all adds up may seem a lot
however what they will all ask is what
am I getting in return for this
increase now now um I've read through
here um I can see of the capital spend
quite a lot is invested in certain areas
including the building that we are
sitting in and yet I'm still to see a
meaningful market research come back to
overviewing
scrutiny and I don't begrudge the
investment if I'm honest but what I
would like to see and I will not be able
to vote on the paper without that
information
as Council won I have to agree we need
some more information um in this paper
I'd like to see the breakdown of the
upper capital projects because we're
District councilors we're not town
councilors or some of us may be and some
of us may be Parish counselors but we're
here to represent the district and I
would like to see how those other
capital projects are impacting on our
parishes our villages
because there seems a huge investment
into one area which at the moment
doesn't sit that comfortably with
me thank
[Music]
you
um
okay members um we have an additional
recommendation put forward by counselor
won and I am going to read that out and
councelor won I sure will correct me if
I'm
wrong that the and I've got move it
closer
sorry uh that the 2024 budget and 2024
to 29 medium-term Financial strategy
report to be Rec recommended to the
executive mindful that there has not
been a line by line scrutiny of the
budget by this
committee so all those in favor please
raise your
hand who's
count all those
against please raise your
hand one two
three and all those abstaining please
raise your hand two
three so that recommendation is carried
um seven for three against and three
abstained um and the comment going back
to the executive is we would like to see
a breakdown of the other capital
projects
line we will
now
members unless I get a nudge from Emily
take the other recommendations are you
happy that we take them on Block
members you don't need to vote on those
they're the recommendations for the
executive forgive me Members we do not
need to vote on those they are the
recommendations for the executive my
error thank you very
much sorry ch if it's okay i' like to
leave now and have a sleep tonight for a
change of course I I think Tim has to
stay I'm afraid have a pleasant
evening uh members now we have um in
front of us agenda item seven which is
the capital and treasury management
strategy um so Tim's got a busy night
with us and Tim will go through this
report for
us thank you chair a brief introduction
um this report sets out the capital and
treasury management strategy y for
20242 it works in tandem with the budget
and medium-term financial strategy there
is not a great deal of material in
relation to borrowing as the council has
no external debt regarding Investments
the parameters and criteria for
Investments are set out in the report
and this report sub views of this
committee will be proposed full Council
on the 20th of February I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you
thank you Tim
members have you any questions for
Tim on the
midterm Financial
strategy M counselor Mrs gson are you
okay I was GNA ask I was going to ask
the question but I think Tim's been
around this block too many times with
this question so I'll Take It
Outside you may ask the question if you
would like
to there we go
um Page 6 point hold make sure I'm on
the right side sorry 7.9 sorry there's
an operational boundary limit figure of
777 and further further along this
amounts been increased to 977 I believe
and um when I looked up what this meant
it means that it's um either debt or
likely expenditure and I've been trying
to find out for a few years now now we
don't have any debt so it's not debt um
likely expenditure is laid out so where
is this figure what is it
about um I'm sure Tim would like to tell
us again thank you chair um this is um a
question that I've been asked a number
of times and it might be because I've
never been able to answer it which is
where it keeps being asked um the the
figure is a historic one it's been in
the accounts for very many many years um
and I've been assured it's not external
debt um yet for treasury management
purposes there's a very prescribed
approach to the way you present your
treasury management strategy and the key
indicators and as councelor gadson's
pointed out there's the operational
boundary limit and there's the
authorized boundary limit and on
7.15 there's a description of the
operational boundary limit which is the
limit Beyond which external debt is not
normally expected to assist exceed be
exceeded um and the authorized boundary
limit is the maximum amount of external
debt permitted by the council now on
face of it those two descriptions are
not that dissimilar but what it means is
on the normal operational basis you
wouldn't exceed your operational
boundary limit which um for most
councils will be Millions if not
hundreds of millions um but then you
would add on a bit for the authorized
boundary limit you'd add in amount which
gave you Headroom so that you're
absolutely sure you weren't going to go
above that figure and you have to come
you have to come up with a figure so the
$977,000 for the authorized boundary
limit compared to the 777 th000 for the
operational boundary limit the
difference of 200,000 is just hroom that
doesn't represent there's no science
behind the extra
200,000 um as regards what the 777 th000
is well it's not external debt um it
might be the product of uh historic
technical accounting adjustment it might
be um internal borrowing when at some
point in the past the council decided to
incurs in capital expenditure they
didn't want to borrow externally so they
borrowed internally and what that means
is they used their cash reserves that
they had available to fund a capital
project and they accounted for it in a
slightly peculiar way rather than just
saying it's a revenue contribution to
Capital um I'm
attempting to commission the treasurer
Treasurer advisor link for for the
council to explore this um I've had a
number of attempts and I've got a
meeting next week with them um it is a
bit open-ended and I'm not offering any
guarantees because they said they're
going to charge a daily rate because
they don't know how long it will take
and if it costs thousands then I'll take
a view that it will be one of life's
mysteries and we won't be able to
identify what it
is thank you Tim and perhaps if you
could give um coun Mrs gone the day and
the time of your meeting she can give
you a call afterwards that's okay yeah I
just want you to add to that it is my
concern about that is it's almost like
this has been a copy and paste exercise
for many years with that figure and
we've never actually got to understand
what it's about so we're carrying this
year on year on and we really do need to
get to the bottom of it yeah I think we
all agree and I think Tim is definitely
on the case for that one
yes you may very briefly chair um the
meeting's on the 6th of February um so
after that please and
the it is the same figure year after
year if it's on the balance sheet
because the opening balance for the next
year is the closing balance from the
previous year so the reason why it's 77
7,000 in 245 is because it was 777000 in
234 it never moves nothing ever changes
about it which is why it's the same
every year um unless we take action to
do something with it it will remain
there forever on the balance sheet and
appear in the treasury management
statud thank you um unless there's any
other questions um we will go to uh the
recommendation A.1 is proposed that the
overview scrutiny committee resolves to
recommend the contents of this treasury
management quarter three report to full
Council all those in favor please raise
your
hand I propose that from theair chair
may have a second thank you Council
award all those in
favor have
skort that is the next item just need to
go back
on
members if uh nobody noticed I actually
read out the wrong recommendation there
so I do apologize um that's my effort at
trying to get through this agenda
tonight and I will apologize and slow
down the recommendation is to recommend
approval of the cap and treasury
management strategy 2024 to full Council
on the 20th of February I propose that
from the chair I have a secondary with
councel Ward all those in favor
unanimous to unanimous thank you very
much
members now we have agenda item
eight um just going to pause one moment
there um I'm going to pause why thank
you very much councelor Newport so
councelor Mrs Mason can rejoin
us
welcome back councelor Mrs Mason
um agenda uh item eight treasury
management quarter 3 review
2024 2023 to 24 um again uh Tim Willis
our director for finance will introduce
the
report thank you um this report sets out
the treasury management position of the
council for the current year as at the
end of December the main highlight is
the excess income generated from
Investments this windfall has been
factored into the latest budget
monitoring report going to the executive
um next week um it has enabled the
creation of a budget mitigation Reserve
which is proposed to be used to
eliminate any budget gaps in the
medium-term financial strategy thank you
thank you members are there any uh
questions for our Director of Finance
councelor
won thank you madam chair
um on
table 8
8.7 um I thought a gramlin had got into
the system um with the name Sonia there
being a very well respected former
member of our staff but I realize now
from a previous report that it stands
for Sterling overnight index average so
uh I won't ask that question um I just
sort of raming have got in h it's a plea
and I do understand it's a controversial
plea but where there are graphs and this
isn't the only one it would be nice if
and I realize it possibly because extra
word these graphs mean very little when
they're in black and white you know I do
remember the famous quot about snooker
you know the black ball behind the blue
or whatever you know so it's not helpful
to have this
pictorial stuff when it's like that but
I did smile about Sonia um the other
observation not a question is that uh on
1.3 page 8.1 uh whilst we acknowledge uh
that high interest rates are a burden
for many U there is the fortuitous uh
amounts that it benefits for Savers in
this case where are a saver and the
majority of the uh funds there uh and
what a pleasant sum that is uh to have a
windfall sum of that time but there
isn't a question now about Sonia so
you'll be pleased to know thank you
madam
chair thank you Council Orton um can I
just remind members um obviously we can
bring our papers Along on in digital
format um our officer um did email out
that if you would like paper copies if
you do want colored copies perhaps Also
let her know at the time okay we are
trying to reduce our carbon footprint so
just bear that in mind but I do
appreciate for some people paper copies
are much easier to read any other
questions
members council Mrs
Mason not not so much a question as an
observation I think all of us know what
GDP
CPI Etc
but I'm assuming that all of us do and I
think it's the wrong assumption and I
know there are explanations of some of
the abbreviations in here but I wonder
if when we have reports that use
abbreviations that the first time that
they're used there could be what that
abbreviation stands for and it's not
just this report I think that would help
with all reports because more uh senior
members will be familiar with the
terminology but for newer members who
are trying to grasp the complexities and
it is a complex
situation I think if across the council
we could make that some sort of
recommendation it would be very
helpful uh thank you council Mrs Mason
um that will be noted please um I agree
especially as members of the public also
read these papers so if we can avoid
acement that's great um any other
members indicating no then we
have councilor Foster thank you chair um
it's a question about s106 money we
Rochford District Council is holding
over a million pounds for could you
please refer to the page that that's
referring not mentioned on here which is
why I'm asking the question investment
income does the interest on the money we
hold for the NHS does it sit in our
income or does it separately go to the
NHS
balance
[Music]
chair I'm not sure which uh income
you're referring to in respect to what
schemes and why it's the NHS but in
general what I can say is that some
section 106 money is provided in the
form of communed TMS which we do invest
and the interest we earn on that we used
to maintain and manage the sites that
the section 106 money was granted for so
it's all reinen within the section 106
development and the scheme attached to
the section 106 I'm not sure if that
answers your questions but any reserves
that we hold any cash reserves we hold
even if they're on behalf of somebody
else or we're holding them until we have
to return them we earn interest on that
money as we did for for example there
was a lot of business rate relief money
that go the government gave local
authorities including Rossford during
covid um and they guessed what the
amount would be and then they clawed it
all back appropriately afterwards we
aren interest on that money whilst we
held it so as a general principle
anything we hold even on behalf of
others unless there's a specific
agreement we would earn interest on that
as well thank
you thank you um so members we have the
recommendation in front of you on page
8.1 is proposed that the overview and
scrutiny committee resolves to recommend
the contents of this treasury management
quarter three report to full Council I
propose that from the chair have I got a
second there please thank you councelor
Mrs Mason all those in favor please
please raise your
hand unanimous that is unanimous members
thank
you moving on members to item nine
agenda item nine is the report on the
progress of work to deliver improvements
to the
deliver to the delivery of the
development management and enforcement
service I'd like to invite Lee neelson
to introduce this
report uh thank you chair good evening
members um so we've got two uh
interrelated reports on the agenda in
front of you this evening item nine the
report we're looking at right now um
provides uh an overview of the service
review that was carried out um spring
last year in relation to the planning
service specifically the development
management uh teams of both authorities
uh that service review then led into a
delivery program essentially 14
recommendations the recommendations were
included uh in the report and it sets
out uh the phases for the various uh
topic areas um pleased to report that
good progress has been made across the
across the program we've just stepped
into phase two um of of the of the
program um there is an overlap between
the two reports that have presented this
evening as in relation to enforcement so
there is more detail in terms of the
enforcement uh aspects of of the service
review in the second uh report but uh uh
hopefully the the reports of interest
and of assistance but happy to take any
questions or
comments thank you so we're going to
take questions first of all on um agenda
item nine um members have you got any
questions councilor Ward yes thank you
very much chairman um well having looked
at appendix
one we have got a
problem um right the way through
where we were discussing on the budget I
think the allocation of funds is
insufficient and I've already made a
recommendation that that needs to be
addressed we have local plan we have
various other things we are unable to
recruit uh as is shown in the
report um I think this is a problem is
resources that are not being funded in
any way shape or form appropriately and
I think this is a big problem that we're
looking at I think actually the
recommendations are a real slap for us
to take into consideration and we need
to seriously seriously look at the
funding within this particular division
because it is totally inappropriate I'm
looking at one of the things that jumped
out at me uh as a question if I may
continue chairman um who are the
planning Improvement board and who
what's the how does the the membership
what is he comprised of is it members is
it officers can I you know have an
Insight please um if we can let the
officer answer that that would be great
thank
you thank you chair so in terms of take
the first comment first in terms of um
finances um is highlighted as uh one of
the the risks so paragraph 3.1 one uh on
page 9.4 I think it is on on the agenda
I'm not sure if it's the same numbers on
on the P that you have um but it
highlights that Finance uh is is is
absolutely important financing resources
is absolutely critical to to any
planning service um and it the report
highlights the need to ensure that that
the the service is resourced
appropriately um there's reference to
planning fees that we National fee
increases um back end of last year in in
in December and it's really important
that those that that fee increase is
reinvested into the service so I
absolutely agree with with with that
point um in terms of the planning
Improvement board um so the planning
Improvement board is an officer group um
which reports uh to to the relevant
strategic director and it's essentially
sits um every four weeks and it is dve
ensuring that there is delivery on all
of those recommendations so essentially
is a check and challenge to make sure
that that that that's happening that
then that Bard then produces a highlight
report which is then presented um up
into CLT and again to ensure that there
is that track of progress and rag status
Etc so if anything was to start to
wobble whether it be through lack of
finances or results or whatever it might
be that would be highlighted we'd be
able to keep in front of that thank you
Le um can we if we can keep it to
questions that would be great thank you
very much Council yes thank you very
much chairman um well it's almost The
Proposal here uh I would like if I may
if I may speak on this one um that there
is a regular report that actually comes
to overview and scrutiny in regards to
this Improvement board so we can
actually monitor what is actually being
improved because it's all very well
having a board that's sitting there if
no one knows what it's doing so I would
like that to come forward as a proposal
from here thank you would would you
therefore like to propose that and frame
your wording and possibly somebody May
second
that on the Fly
okay I propose that let me get it right
that the planning and Improvement board
reports its findings to overview and
scrutiny scrutiny whatever on a regular
basis
do you have a second
there
quarterly
cly councelor Foster second that
recommendation so members just so you're
aware this isn't much recommendation for
the report this is a recommendation that
this um planning
committee comes back to us on a
quarterly basis just to with a report on
the their
progress
okay so all all those in favor of this
recommendation um counselor Mrs Paige
yeah thank
you thank you councilor um councilor Mrs
gson did you want to ask a question yeah
on resources um page
9.2 um
2.3 um for the director F Le um where
are we with the filling of the senior
plan and post because you've got a part
timer but that's obviously under
resourced um have we made any
progress thank you chair um it is
disappointing that um despite adverts
being placed in
professional journals that um we haven't
been able to to recruit into that into
that post it is picked up in part in the
next report but uh temporary results is
going into that post to be able to fill
that we've had almost like0 three of FTE
that's been filling that but it needs to
be the 100% um FTE so there is temporary
results going in for uh for for several
months and then we'll need to go back
out to the market to try to fill that is
tly difficult to find planning
professionals but
it it's not sustainable in a long period
of time um for for for the team to
absolve um uh you know the additional
pressure so they need to to make sure we
recruit into
that thank you Le uh council Mrs
Mason thank you chair um this isn't so
much a question as a request we have in
appendix one a table a table that gives
us dates from September to December from
January to March Etc in The Narrative of
the report there's an
explanation that of what has happened in
that table it would be helpful if we're
having a table for the table to be
updated so that it so that we don't have
to cross reference all the time um so
for example phase one you've got the
rationale that's fine but the the the
outcome should be also on that table or
it should say complete or something
rather rather than having to scrubble
around and look for it so that's just a
request that the presentation is perhaps
altered in future so that it's easier
for us to
read the other thing I think all members
are concerned about the number of
Enforcement cases that the council has
and
the um difficulty we having clearing the
B clog have has any of this
work had a direct result on the number
of cases
outstanding thank you chair um in terms
of that the first point around the
presentation table I'm just listening to
the to the debate just there around the
future report so absolutely will make
sure that that's included within that um
in terms of the so it's again referenced
in the report
but systems processes and resources and
structures are all inter interwound
within this program the structures um
and the resilience and capacity that's
built within those structures is
obviously key to that um so that is part
of this phase that we're working through
um you''ll be aware of the ti or four um
appointments that happened just before
Christmas that had to happen in terms of
sequence before we then move into the
structures so that is part of part of
that part of that work mad chairman can
I come just come back on that would it
be possible to put the number of cases
outstanding on enforcement on the
reports in future because I know that's
quite a cont contentious issue and it's
often asked and and then it seems to get
lost so I wonder if that's information
that we could just have flagged up on a
regular basis if we're having a cly
report would that be acceptable to the
officers yes the officers just um
acknowledge that they be great thank you
um members any other question so um so
if we just um have a look all um this
report is for us to note so is that
noted members thank thank you um and Lee
um you are um going to introduce agender
item 10 planning enforcement thank you
uh thank you chair um so this report
specifically refers to enforcement
activity in the last three quarters 2023
um which sets out more of a I guess more
of a in-depth analysis of some of the
cases so the cases that have been
presented to to the authority um which
have been uh closed which have been
resolved through negotiation or where
cases where there's been no breach
identified so it's just to try to give a
flavor more of a statistical report more
of a flavor for members on what the
pressures are within the team and again
because of that read across between
which report just been talking about in
terms of structures I think it just
really does highlight um the the
importance of of of ensuring that that
the team are resourced and we have that
capacity within within the team
specifically within the enforcement
team
thank you Lee um Council award please
keep to
questions and statements thank you thank
you thank you
um I I'm I'm just going to make an
assumption I assume that with the
reporting back this will be included in
the reporting on ongo I think uh
councilor Mason Mrs Mason has asked for
that so that's one one item the the
other is there have been a lot of
historic cases and I can see that you
had a clear up within the report now
obviously I I know from experience that
some of those cases because of uh the
fact of lack of Staff became out of time
and I do know of several that became out
of time and therefore unenforceable
because they were out of time and and I
find that extremely disappointing uh
when that occurs now is there a why in
which uh where there are items there
there where there are conditions on on
quite a lot of major developments that
these major
developments they are flagged up that
there is a time limit on them and that
they are
inspected um that's a concern I do have
if we go to the
appendix you've got it here uh
Enforcement cases awaiting appeal
outcome
or compliance or compliance now do you
know if any of these have complied in
anyway or are you waiting to find out if
they have been complied
with thank you chair um apologize I
don't have the the the knowledge of the
individual cases themselves so I
wouldn't be able to say that but in
terms of the the appendices that have
been put together this is setting out
indict what what the case that are
waiting appe pill or or that compliance
it may well be that enforcement notices
have been served and the time period has
been set for for compliance and it's
under a period of monitoring and then
obviously it would then need to uh we
then may need to escalate um in terms of
the actions that that may mean
prosecution if it wasn't complied with
incense the steps in enforcement
notice if I may
help um
10.8 um last item 7 27 Barrymore
walk okay just to help you that
particular site is now
tidy so just confirming that that TI is
now sign that that site is tidy thank
you thank you um members any other
questions for
Le councel Mrs Mason thank you I'm I'm
not sure if this is going to be possible
or even desirable but I wonder if that
the officer and the committee would want
to consider whether there should be some
member involvement in the enforcement
decisions I know they're of a technical
nature however we pass a planning
application at development
committee members and officers then put
conditions on those conditions have then
hopefully complied with or Al aled again
they would normally come back for
alteration to development committee yet
when they're not complied with
development committee members are not
necessarily aware of that therefore
they're not aware of the effect of the
conditions that they're putting on and
whether or not they're reasonable I
think it might be helpful if there was
some sort of member involvement and I've
got no idea how and no idea if it would
fit in with the process or where but I
would like it to be considered if
possible thank
you they if you'd like to come back on
that I think it's quite a reasonable
suggestion thank you chair it is I'm
just trying to work out how that would
that would fit into the process and um
it may be something that we might just
have to take away and give something
consideration to it's a legal question
as well yes I wasn't expecting an answer
tonight I think it's a a complex request
but I think it might help in the long
run with better initial decisions if
members are aware of of why conditions
aren't um carried out and why the
enforcement is then effectively waved in
some cases then perhaps they would
reconsider putting those conditions on
in the first place or make them stronger
I don't know but it's just a thought
thank
you any other members um councelor
Foster I think you'll be the last on
this item thank you thank you chair um
on page
10.2 the table shows 28% of CAS is
resolved through negotiation and at the
bottom it explains that could be
alterations or retrospective planning do
you have a sense of how many of those
are actually achieve through
retrospective planning and when
the when the um the person involved is
encouraged to make a retrospective is it
in the reasonable understanding that
it'll be
[Music]
approved thank you ch um I don't have
the the break down the sense of of how
that how that percentage breaks down but
in terms of the pro typical Pro approach
to an enforcement case would be when a
breach has been identified the first
Port of Call would be to look for a
remedy to that and if it is a
development that
is potentially compliant with the
development plan and potentially
something that could be able to approv
then clearly the first step would be to
invite a planning application if it's
something that is so fundamentally
contrary to a development plan then
you'd naturally move to to to
enforcement action fairly swiftly but
where there is a potential for it to be
acceptable um then that's when the
invitation would typically be be
offered thank does that answer your
question councelor Foster if I may just
come back
briefly these um retrospectives would we
expect them to go to development
committee or will be decided by
officers um thank you chair I guess it
would depend on the scale and nature of
the development that's that's taking
place um if it's something that you
wouldn't necessarily expect to go to
development committee planning committee
um then it would typically be a be an
item that would be delegated in that
sense of that decision but clearly if it
was a significant uh breach
environmental breach something of of
significant scale then perhaps that
would warrant um a high level of of of
of decision making okay thank
you um Lee just on there it might be
useful for Ward members to know about
some of those changes because often
we're the first on the ground to hear
ex's put in for this and now they're
building this what's going on so it
could be quite
helpful Jeff for me um there's reference
in the early report around reporting
Arrangements that's a perfect example
course super um thank you there I don't
think there's any other questions so
again uh members this um report is just
for noting is that noted members thank
you um Lee welcome to R District Council
and you're more than welcome to leave hi
thank
you uh moving on to agenda item 11
members um it is the one team
transformation program strategic partner
with b brenwood a council qu to three
update um Greg Campbell our director
will introduce this
report thank you chair um I've got a
couple of updates following some
questions I've received before the
committee this evening and I'll go
through those questions then obviously
open up to any questions that you may
have um question one was around the
stasis of Staff members and shared
designation across both uh councils what
I can confirm is that those staff who
have been through the service review
process REM uh sorry who have not been
through the service review process
remain with their designated Council and
are not working across both councils and
further what I can confirm is that where
the service review has taken place and
there is a one team in place and the
staff have been uh put into position
those structures should now be on the
members portal and that should have been
communicated to you if it hasn't I will
check tomorrow and make sure that that
is communicated to you and every time
that happens we'll update that portal
with a new structure um the second
question refers to again managing staff
and the allocation of time spent across
both
authorities what I can say about this is
that those services that have been
through the review process have done so
under the governance Arrangements that
are place and therefore being through
both leaders of the two
organizations those that are presented
to those leaders and being agreed have
made sure that it's a 5050 split between
the two authorities and that that
matches the resources and the work is
identified the next couple of questions
are more HR related so I've taken advice
from them um hopefully I'll do them
Justice um I've been asked is there
additional cost to
having inter staff as opposed to staff
in post the response there is more than
likely inter interim staff cost slightly
more due to the fees for example however
there are exceptions where actually
staff that are actually employed by the
council are slightly more expensive
because we have the on costs that are
there as well uh the next question
around this was how to sta retention
levels lie at the moment compared with
other local authorities the updated
figure that I've got up to the 31st of
January 2024 is currently our turnover
uh at Rochford is
10% uh the closest we can compare that
to at the moment is the LGA who provide
these figures and their last figure was
in 20121 and their turnover figure was
14% at the moment and then the last
question was around exit interview
questions and around whether there were
any common themes out of the 14
resignations only one exit questionnaire
was returned uh this covered a number of
reasons for leaving um and further to
this what we know about the 14
resignations is that we know four other
four of the officers left for work in
the private sector and two left for
another local Authority um there were no
common themes
identified and lastly just to update uh
members uh at previous meetings it's
been asked about a consultation with
resident we undertook that questionnaire
questionnaire consultation just before
Christmas it closed yesterday um I've
got some initial feedback from that
consultation we asked uh residents
whether they are aware of the
partnership that was taking place and um
whether they were in support of the
partnership and what we did also uh
allow them to do is per to write some
comments if they had any about the
partnership in place uh in responses we
had 78 responses those that were aware
45 said they were aware 33 said they
weren't 25 said they were in support of
the partnership 53 said they were not
and I haven't got obviously not obvious
say obviously I haven't got all the
responses because that would take a
little bit more time to go through them
and whether there were any common
themes thank you chair um happy to take
any
questions thank you Greg
members uh Council
Orton thank you madam chair um it was
really pleasing to hear the section1
officer refer to the fact of uh uh the
budget Gap uh in rodford early on it is
to the initiatives of the one team uh to
no borrowing no interest payments no
capital repayments and it's a delight to
hear those sorts of themes are
continuing uh because I believe
passionately that the survival of local
government generally uh is through
creative scheme so I'm refreshed to know
that there is continuing
support however um if we are going to
use 14% as a benchmark and say that's
fine uh I don't agree with that I think
10% is too high um uh I think anything
in excess of 5% uh from the official
personel management bodies uh would be a
little bit of a concern in an
organization so I'm afraid I'm not
reassured with the 14% figure uh and us
being 10% ver dat figure and totally
supportive of the one team uh program um
but we know the difficulty in recruiting
in the public sector uh we know the fact
that any program like this and this was
always a risk leads to uncertainty that
can lead to difficulties with morale um
and uh it's been going on now for two
years uh and um as think it's time it
came to an end and when you look at the
list here there are a number of uh
issues where there is slippage and it's
overdue um and I understand that that
goes on in investment projects but my
appeal is can it get sorted out pretty
quickly um because it is leading uh and
the practicalities we all talk to staff
in conjunction and there are issues with
morale and I would suggest it is
uncertainty because there are
opportunities outside our Authority and
if people are thinking thinking I've got
to wait another six months before I know
what I'm going to do um and I've got a
choice to go to another role which may
be a higher paid role it will happen so
it's a plea to get this sorted out um I
please accept the fact that I don't have
the sort of influence that I did have at
the start of this program but I'm sure
people would want to speed it up get it
done uh because on paper it looks good
uh but the practicalities the
implication that's a plea it's not a
question thank you madam chair thank you
Council Orton um just a remind
recommendations here are that the
committee notes the progress of the one
team transformation program but
recommendation to the committee makes
any recommendations to the executive for
consideration did you want to make a
recommendation I think the
recommendation is that the program board
uh examine the program and look for ways
in which it can be speeded up uh I'm not
wording it particularly well but the
monitoring officer is always absolutely
excellent at converting um words off the
top of my head to local government speak
uh but certainly speed it up in a way uh
that reduces and minimize uncertainty
within uh the the staff and actually
settles the settles The Authority um
because we want stability within the
authority in terms of progressing uh the
delivery of services but I'm sure
there's work going on to try and turn
that into a decent recommendation thank
you while we allow Emily some time Tim
did you want to come back on anything
else that Council won raised at all um
yes thank you Council thank you chair um
I'll probably should make myself clear
the 14% is the lga's median across the
whole country of um turnover so it
wasn't their their target as it were and
totally agree you know we want to drive
that that down as much as possible um
the other point being about yet we want
to get some of that slippage back we are
looking at plans on how we're
approaching that and amending what we
are doing to make sure we can bring
those to fruition as quickly as possible
and take on the point that we're always
communicating with staff we really do
try hard and we keep working at that to
make sure they're kept informed of what
is going on but as you point out we are
going through transformation there is
always going to be some nervousness and
what we do is try and communicate the
process the timings everything so they
are fully informed all the time but
thank you for the coms thank you chair
thank you um I think Emily will have
worded your words um quite succinctly so
I'll pass over to Emily to read those
out if you're inre in agreement with
those thank you chair um so the
recommendation that I've captured is
that the one team program be drawn to a
close in line with the original time
scale of two years to minimize any
further uncertainty for
staff in order to stabilize the
business so I'll add and it and in order
to stabilize the business you know I
feel as if I could have written that
myself thank
you would you like to second that
councilor or a
second um if I come back to you then on
your question because Council Lor was
next if that's okay so
um okay so we're going to take a vote on
that recommendation um
members you like me to read it out
again um recommendation is that the one
team program be drawn to a close in line
with the original time scale of two
years to minimize any further
uncertainty
uncertainty for staff and in order to
stabilize the
business all those in favor please raise
your hand can I ask for some clarity
before we take a vote please or if we're
not able to debate
it yeah what what's your question
Council um the original two time scale
you put the original two years but when
did it start when would it be completed
by I think we need to know that time
scale thank
you I'm I'm sure um Greg will correct me
if I'm I'm wrong but essentially we're
due um we're coming up to the end of
that two-year time scale so formally the
council went into partnership in
January
yeah
thank you so that renders that slightly
academic but nevertheless thank
you you want chair just to I suppose
that the partnership started in January
2022 the service reviews didn't start
till later that year it was more uh
around the the September time for
service review started Communications
and HR started earlier around May that
year but the full service reviews didn't
start until around September
2022 could I recommend within this
financial year so that will give to the
end of
April if I can come back I think that's
a totally reasonable time frame the
point we're making is we want to clear
up uncertainty amongst our Workforce
just quickly as possible and if they've
got a and I I totally take c m Mason's
point I think he's absolutely right to
put a a time constraint on it so that
seems to be reasonable bearing in mind
the 25th of January 2024 has passed
thank you uh Madam chair if I can come
back i' take Council won's point but
we've just heard that the staff
alterations didn't start till September
so if we're doing two years that would
be September which I think would be
reason why I I think quality is better
than Russ in personally but um yeah it's
just a point of view if you want you
originally wanted two years two years
from September is
September um we have councelor won's
proposal on the a recommendation on the
table um it is that the one team program
be drawn to a close by the end of this
financial year to minimize any further
uncertainty for staff and in order to
stabilize the
business so all those in favor that is
um uh your recommendation that you've
got there I was can I move an amendment
if that's what I was asking Council wood
if he would consider amending it because
he didn't originally put the date
in yeah um I would like to support
Meers gonna let let Emily speak first
our monitoring officer thank
you thank you chair I think it's
probably just worth clarifying the one
team transformation program time scales
because whilst uh my colleague has
talked about the first service reviews
being completed in September it did
begin the process began before that um
and so we have been working to when we
phased the program we've been working to
the program being concluded at the end
of this financial year so the
recommendation as it stands now um does
reflect the original time scales of of
the program um I think it's important
that members recognize that this
recommendation would me and of course
this is being recommended to the
executive um but this recommendation
would mean that not necessarily all
teams will have been able to complete a
one team service review at that point
but the program does need to reach an
end and actually we need to move as an
authority into a program of continuous
service improvement and continuous
transformation so there may continue to
be changes in teams but it won't
necessarily be under the badge of the
one team program because that will have
drawn to a
close thank you and then unless I'm uh
wrong we are only making this
recommendation to the
executive um so I will read it out one
more time the recommendation is that the
one team program be drawn to a close by
the end of this financial year to
minimize any further uncertainty
for staff and in order to stabilize the
business all those in
favor all those against please none
those
abstaining those that didn't
vote
uh councilor lambor you had the question
next yes um I'd like to uh thank Greg
for answering some of my questions that
I put to him
previously and he answered them just now
but I still to have um two
two basic problems the first is I cannot
understand why as been this Council RDC
being the junior partner in this
partnership why we are having a 5050
split on the costs for the senior
management team I I've worked many years
through my life in consultancies Banks
insurance companies and where you work
on multiple projects you have project
codes and you book your time against the
work you do why we haven't got a system
like that so that we can ACC accurately
allocate the timing Council would you
like to let Greg answer that first
question um and then that well I Haven
finished it but okay um rather than yeah
thank you chair thank you councilor am
um I I wouldn't say R are a junior
partner at all in this relationship it's
a 50/50 partnership as I see it and the
management structure that we have is a
50/50 split about the world work that we
take on across both organizations and I
think that filters down um in the
service reviews that we do if it isn't
then the service review that would come
forward obviously there's a time frame
on that now would show a different split
which should also uh be reflective in
the financial implications of that
service
review thank you Greg so um the the
reason I sort of interjected council
ambon is because it is a 50/50 split um
we don't know though do we we've only
we' only got we've got no
empirical evidence that there is a 5050
spit anyway okay my second Point Greg
would you mind just coming back on how
that is monitored if that's possible
please a apologies chair I'm pulling
pulling Rank and um dumping in on this
one um so the terms of the original
section 1113 agreement between between
the two councils um when entering into
the partnership was that it was very
much on a 50/50 basis both Partners were
equal and both Partners would receive an
equal share of the resource now that
agreement does also require that we
undertake an annual review of that split
of costs because another key principle
of the partnership is that neither
Council can support uh can subsidize the
other one so on an annual basis that
split of costs is reviewed viewed to
check that it still is accurate as a
50/50 split and if for example there
were some areas in the council where
this the service delivery model was
different and therefore the cost of
portion should be higher in one than the
other we would make that adjustment so
um the basis the Baseline is 5050 but it
is reviewed and it is kept under review
and who monitors that
review have we seen that this is that
shouldn't that become part of this
report yeah I mean it can be it be
through the Section 151 off understating
that review as well that part of it with
the head of P service Jonathan
Stevenson um so so just for clarity
Council lamp on where we've asked for
that to be included once the reviews
done in a future
report second question is on the staff
retention you say that roch's got um
10%
um the national average is 14 what is it
for
Brentwood sorry chair I wasn't asked
that question at the start so I haven't
got that figure sorry I was only asked
um for the retention Lake for Ro sorry I
so I didn't have that to hand sorry but
that that that's fine Greg perhaps you
could circulate it to to members
apologies that would be irrelevant
Benchmark against whether we're
performing as well as the other half of
our partnership without that we still
don't know where we
are thank you councilor
Ward yes thank you chairman I just want
to come back on an issue we does get
flagged up in the report which is morale
I think it's a very important uh part of
uh both authorities but I just wanted to
get an understanding of the position of
both authorities in as much you know
there is a big difference in the working
environment in Brentwood and in Rochford
big difference and I'm wondering if the
problems that possibly we're having here
is a contributing factor because I've
been to Brentwood and it's lovely
facilities everything is lovely I'm
afraid it's not the same here so uh
obviously with the ADP that would have
been going on to try and improve staff
conditions if I may say within this
district is that a contributing factor
to
morale um I think all factors can be a
contributing factor to morale um
sometimes it is the environment the
staff of the office environment it can
be um things like working from home
nowadays suit some people some don't I
think what we can say is across both
local authorities uh we're quite
flexible we're agile in the way that we
approach things I think with the plans
that we do have in place or looking to
have in place increasing and improving
the working environment will improve
some of that staff morale um and I hope
it will have an influence in the future
um I can't say whether it impacts on
everyone that works there because some
people prefer that style of working in
smaller offices some don't like the open
open kind of office that brenwood has at
the moment so it could have some impact
thank you Greg
Council thank you madam chair look I
think Council Lambo makes a really good
point um when this all started remember
we had two separate workforces uh and
the whole idea was to get on with the
one team
transformation um so you put in Fairly
simplistic systems to cope with that
rather than get bogged down with the
bureaucracy of cross charging but
actually if I think about it and I'm
sure there's others um you know there's
partnership Arrangements on things like
planning with other authorities coun
Point um but just taking it high level
Leisure we Outsource brewood insource
waste we Outsource brimwood insource
housing we Outsource brewood insource so
there will be larger teams there and I
think council ambor is absolutely right
at this point to be saying we need to
start looking at the cost structures
because uh those teams are a mismatch
between the way the two authorities do
it because Rochford has to pay its costs
to Outsource providers um and therefore
we shouldn't be double charging so I
think he makes a really valid point
Thank You Council Orton um we've already
um agreed that point and a report is
coming for following the review as
requested by councilor Lor um any other
members have you any
questions so
members if we look at page um
11.1 we have the recommendation first of
all the committee notes the progress of
the one team transformation program is
that noted members thank you and we have
a recommendation that has been put
forward by councelor won um and agreed
by the
group thank you um and and that that is
that the one the one team program be
drawn to a close by the end of this
financial year to minimize any further
uncertainty for staff and in order to
stabilize the business I have to ask you
again all those in
favor all those
against and any members
abstaining thank you
members and moving
on we have agenda item
12 agenda item 12 is the cost of living
update we have
um me we have uh Kim Anderson to
introduce this report please thank you
members thank you chair um this is just
to provide a bit of an update report to
members um um to overview in scrutiny
committee um around the work around the
cost of living crisis um there is um
plan to be an all members briefing with
more detail in the report rather than
present tonight because it was a very
tight agenda um just looking at some of
the highlights um and I will also go to
uh councelor Gooding if she wants to add
anything more in
um we have continued with the activate
program so that's the holiday um activ
and food program that's run through
active
essics um and we've got um High numbers
of um children that were in seat of free
School meals attending those um
activities during the summer and um
Christmas
holidays cost of living Road Show so
there was two Road shows that were done
in
2023 and members of this committee
committed another £7,000 to roll out
some more Road shows um so we we've had
one in great wakering there's another
one due in great wakering because one
was on a weekday and then another one's
going to be followed up on a
Saturday um but there are further ones
planned across um The District in
hawkley holbridge
um I'm still waiting on figures around
the warm hubs but I'll get that from
rabs who are cating that information for
myself
um and obviously we've got figures from
ciens ofice Bureau and the number of
people that they're reaching during this
um crisis if I can still call that
because there's an element of some of
that um crisis is reduced with
um fuel prices coming down as well as um
utility prices coming
down um again um I can provide more
information as part of the all members
briefing to everybody councelor Gooding
I don't know if you want to add anything
else
thank you Kim I think you've pretty much
covered um what you wanted to bring
forward to the overview scrutiny um the
other perhaps was the the voluntary
sector grant that was also um put into
the Hub and they with their ,000 they
were able to support 54 families um with
10 and 20 increments and 154 people Ben
benefited from receiving the vouchers as
part of this work that's been going out
to support families in the
community thank you Kim thank you
counselor Mrs goodin um members just so
you're aware um Kim had come with the
idea this um uh meeting of a
presentation similar to the one that we
had before and mindful of the time that
we had um my suggestion was that this
would be good for an all member briefing
so that all members are aware of what
we're doing with the cost of living
crisis here uh but members have you got
any questions for um Kim yes um
councelor sparin thank you chairman uh
Kim you've you've highlighted six
particular projects here is this just
going to be a where the district council
will be signposting where to get advice
or is there actual physical contribu I
mean I I see on one you've got uh
support to
businesses
[Music]
um what what is that other than sign
posting where businesses can go and get
support or is there some physical
contribution that they can apply
for what we've done under the cost of
living is it's break it down to themes
at the end of the day so there was
support for businesses so there was some
business grants initially I think when
we had covid Etc what comes out of that
um I think going forward it's probably
working with our Economic Development
teams um but the authority and how they
can support businesses and whether
that's sign posting some other benefits
they may be eligible for that they're
not aware of um that can be around the
green agenda as well that how can they
reduce their overheads in that regard so
I think there's another elements I think
from our perspective we're here to
facilitate sign post and and promote
awareness of what support is available
over those kind of themes that we've got
on the website thank
you any other members indicating to
ask um I I will just say um wake Crim um
had one of the first of these I think it
might be because we've missed out before
so um and it was hugely well attended
far more than a lot of other events that
we' have put on in in the community um
so please when they come to your area go
out there tell your residents about them
um the feedback from residents has been
excellent um so thank you to councelor
goodin and Kim um for putting on those
events with the partners um who are
numerous to mention uh councilor but
you've got a
question thank you madam chair um I just
wonder um and thank you for your report
Kim and councelor Gooding um I just
wonder against these themes
whether there could be a little bit of a
shopping list next time of what those
themes mean in Practical terms um
because I'm just looking at it and sort
of struggling you you've given an answer
about the businesses um but essentially
that was the government grants I believe
I don't I'm not aware that we gave
grants and so it would just be helpful
to have a little bit you know to help us
understand when it talks about to go
green um great but what what does that
mean because there's a lot of go green
stuff which involves a capital
expenditure and we talk about cost of
living here um so it's just trying to
get in our heads which boxes they fit in
so here's a question could we just have
a little bit more explanation against
the specific themes well I'll do is add
that into the all member briefing that's
useful that was exactly what I was going
to say your you're you will be furnished
with all the information that you need
counselor Mrs Gadson um Kim just a quick
question in your all me M briefing will
you be addressing the credit
union um motion that was put forward
where we are with
that I was just about to say um please
thank you um Ju Just to a Kim we will be
bringing back a report to this Committee
in March on that particular matter if
that's okay thank
you my apologies councelor Mrs gon I
thought I had mentioned that it's coming
forward next month and I had to check
that I was right um Joe it was just that
there was going to be a member briefing
so I didn't know whether there was going
to be any information in that thank you
of course um Council Ward thank you
chairman uh just on the various meetings
and various um well let's get the right
term I know uh glad Council gladon
actually CL Road shows that's it yeah
the road shows um it would be use
if the parishes were sent notice and
even for the various boards that go out
yes I can answer that they've done an
extremely
um excellent job um they involv the
parishes the churches you name the
organizations they got in touch with
them to make sure even taking posters
down
there the reason I asked chairman is
because I haven't seen any because
because I normally stick them in the um
bus shelters which I I do and the notice
bolts and I haven't actually seen any so
it would be useful it may be going on
but I haven't seen any that's why I
asked as soon as they come out to your
area you all know about them I'm sure uh
members any other questions just Joe
just a quick suggestion if we do get
credit unions off the ground they would
be quite good um to be along to these
Road shows to be
included um the officers all not in
agreement with here um so members there
is no recommendation is just for us to
receive this report and obviously I
encourage you all to go to the members
briefing where we can find out so much
more about these
events thank you very much
Kim
um agenda item number 13 review of the
council's outside
bodies um I I will introduce this report
um in
brief we had only I believe um and the
officer May corre correct me 13
responses back from our survey that we
sent out to all members just asking for
feedback on groups we appreciate that
not every member will have been engaged
with an outside body or partnership but
even just the feedback and say they
haven't would be useful and we know that
quite a few have who didn't respond so
we're actually going to put that survey
out again to the members who did not
respond to gather some more information
and at the same time officers will be
cating their information to try and PRI
prioritize um and also of course mark
those bodies and partners which are
statutary for us to have an attendance
uh councelor
Myers the only thing I would say about
the survey is when you actually took it
when it asked which outside body you
join joined or been active in there was
no space for none so you had to put
something in one of the boxes to even
attempt to fill
it so it might be I to stick a zero box
in it there we are um the officer noted
that so that will be changed council Mrs
Mason yes I had the same difficulty and
the other thing I would point out you
may only have had 13 responses I think
Council M have just explained why and
also you've got to remember that I had a
look before I came out actually only 18
members on the council at present were
on the previous administration and not
necessarily all of those were on outside
bodies so perhaps if you're not getting
the number of responses you want you're
expecting responses where people haven't
got experience and can't give you the
answer or perhaps if you know the people
that haven't responded I don't know if
it's en ominous or not you you could
Target your requests for information
because I would say 13 out of 18 is and
that's assuming that every one of the
previous administration members was on
an outside body which I think is
unrealistic I would say that you've
actually got quite a high number of
responses councel Mrs Mason um I was
been polite members will be targeted
that didn't respond where we know
perhaps they could contribute to us okay
um we we just want to make sure we've
got meaningful and qu quantitative data
to actually um make decisions um thank
you so that report will be coming back
to us councelor sparing thank you chair
thank you chairman um in the past I've
attended a number of these uh outside
bodies um can I just draw the attention
on page 13.9 it says gra Community
Center which uh we are the landlords
effectively of and it's least from rord
District Council says the meetings are
quarterly I think in five years I have
never been invited asked to attend or
been involved in anything with brange
Community Center it is an issue and I
would like officers to try and address
this if we're going to attend a meeting
they've got to have them thank you
chairman that thank you councelor sparin
that's noted and that's very helpful
information thank
you so members moving
on
okay I just had to check councelor
Gooding because as you're not part of
the committee but at my discretion yes
please so the ess6 Heritage Trust um it
says here that there's uh three meetings
per anom I have not received one
invitation so if just wanted to draw
that to the officer's attention so that
I could receive that because I am on
that thank you
um I if it's in relation to the
report please just speed that into the
officers so that we can um if it's
similar sort of information if it's not
keep your hand bre councelor won thank
you madam chair Madam chair uh on page
13 101 um I just had a little bit of a
smile um for a seller joint committee
whoever responded there um they attended
20 to 30 per year um so I would question
the qualitative nature of the data
because I think to my certain knowledge
there's only about four or five meetings
a year so you know we got to be a little
bit careful of this data 20 to 30 yes as
an ess6 ess6 County councelor um so you
know we got to make sure that rubbish in
rubbish out but actually got to make
make sure it's helpful to us um so I
think that's another side of the member
feedback
bit we we will pick those
up so members that that will come back
to this working group in our April
meeting that gives us time to address
some of those issues counc
Lyon um yes I did actually return um my
answers also the ra Mount um has not met
and I have chased it up so um can we
also CH Chas up the Committees to
actually you're chasing us up to give
responses can we re chase them up to
give responses to us of why the why
we're not being invited to the
Committees yeah that that will be noted
but it will in the survey if we can put
that sort of information there that will
be very useful and officers will pick
that up thank you um agenda item 14 we
have the key decisions that uh document
memb so if you could all go to decisions
document so key decisions document
members um if we can just go through
these so page
one voluntary seor grants allocation any
questions on
that next item is the Leisure contract
procurement any questions on that
members and then on page two we have the
UK shared Prosperity fund any questions
at
all thank you and Council Orton your
comment from earlier this evening is
noted against
that thank you members so if we can move
on to the work
plan you have the work plan in front of
you our next meeting on the 5th of March
at the moment it has the review of of
Engagement with stakeholders and
residents um I have also asked um as
requested for
the um an update on M Hall from the
recommendations made at overview and
scrutiny
on I believe it was the 5th of February
2023 so we report back to us at that
meeting and we also have an update on
the credit union coming
forward so just so the members are aw
aware for the fifth of March councilor
sparing thank you chairman I think it
was March or April last year um I
proposed when I was in the
administration that we should introduce
a three-hour free parking for disabled
um it was quite strongly argued at the
time that there should have been a
surveys done one thing other I'm pleased
to see that that has finally been
administered but we were asked or I was
asked at that time to come back
subsequently with a report to show the
amount of people that be using it where
they came from etc etc but no report has
ever been forthcoming chairman thank
you at the moment we've got two items on
the um April
2024 meeting Council in we can ask for
that report to come back
then anybody else any other members
councelor Mrs
Gadson um just a quick question Joe um
page two of the key decision document um
it says UK shared Prosperity fund but
there's there's no decision in the
Box um we've moved on to the I
know would you like pop that over an
email thank
you um councelor
mil with regard to something perhaps to
consider to bring in to later on to the
work plan is the the review a review of
the management and the uh and the
arrangements to deal with that of the
Dutch Cottage and finchfield and the
responsibilities and funding and offers
the time spent on it it seems to be
soaring
um from that point of view
um I would like that call
in uh thank you uh members in
agreement thank you yeah looks like you
have the support their Council um I will
have to put that to offices to come back
to us with a time scale I I can ask for
it to come at April but I don't know if
that will give them enough time so if
not it may be in the next Municipal year
thank you members anything
else well then thank you members we are
M on 9:30 so I don't have to ask anybody
if they would like to stay any longer
thank you very much for helping us get
through a very Hefty agenda good night
[Music]
members